hey you guys
welcome to flickers of fear doing
another movie review
and doing another kind of 60s
under scene kind of classic i want to
say just like a couple weeks back when i
did night tide
i've kind of been going through shutter
and i'm trying to like catch up on like
some older movies that i maybe missed
out on or hadn't heard of or anything
like that
because i was actually going to do a
different movie this week but then i was
kind of scrolling through shutters
you know kind of old black and white
movies and i was kind of like man that's
like that
sounds really good and like the pedigree
of it uh had me really interested and
it's about witches and you guys know how
much
i love movies about witchcraft so i was
like okay well i'm gonna do that one
instead
so this is a 1962 movie in the u.s
it's known as burn witch burn uh
although i think in other territories
strictly in the uk
it was actually released as knight of
the eagle which
kind of makes sense because of the end
but honestly i kind of think burn
witchburn is a better title
just going to say and this is actually
an
adaptation of a novel by fritz leiber
called conjour wife which i think i read
when i was a teenager now that i'm
thinking about it
this is actually not the first
adaptation of it i think there had been
another one
in the 40s because the novel came out
i think it came out like serialized in
like 1943 or something like that and
then like it came out as a book
10 years later so it was adapted i think
in the 40s with lon chaney jr and i
think it was called
weird woman and then there was an
adaptation in 1979 with terry garr
but i can't remember what it was called
i'll probably like think of it in a
minute
but yeah so this weirdly it's like even
though they've adapted it three times so
far
it's never adapted by its name which i
don't know why that is but like i said
so in the u.s it's called burn witch
burn in the uk and other territories
it's called knight of the eagle
uh as far as i know it's on shutter in
the us and i believe it's also on
shutter in the uk because i saw another
uh an irish guy reviewing and he said
that he'd watched on shutter uk
so it's on there as well so it's like in
1962 it's a black and white
movie and this movie i'm just surprised
that i never i'd heard the title
kind of like around but i'd never
actually sat down and watched it and
actually when i first sat down to watch
it i thought
that it was this other movie that i'd
seen that i can't even remember the name
of now but that was kind of like an old
black and white movie that kind of had
some voodoo doll like action going on in
it
that was also from the 60s uh but this
was not that this was one that i hadn't
seen before
and this movie i gotta say this was a
lot of
fun it's like a real it's not wacky zany
i don't mean fun like that but i mean
just like fun
just really really entertaining and
really suspenseful
and it just has just i don't know it
just had a really really cool vibe to it
i really enjoyed it quite a lot
and uh it seems that most of the people
on shutter did as well because it easily
has five skulls and like pretty much
everyone is like how did i never see
this movie before it's like so awesome
so especially if you really like 60s
horror if you really like
witchcraft type stuff like suspenseful
type stuff like that
then this should be right up your alley
i'd really really dug it a lot
so uh the movie starts out and i love
this i knew i was gonna
love this movie like in the first two
minutes
because it's just a black screen and
then you have the voice
of paul freeze who you know he did like
a lot of
uh he did the narration for the haunted
mansion like at disney world disneyland
and stuff
and you know millions of other things he
always has a spooky like that really
spooky voice so he does this opening
narration where he's basically saying in
this movie
there's gonna be like black magic spells
and everything like that so he's in
toning a spell to like protect everybody
that's like watching the boobies so you
don't get like some
black magic [ __ ] happening to you so i
appreciated that but yeah so just like i
really really liked that
aspect of it it sounds cheesy when i say
it like that but i just thought it was
like really charming
and i love that guy's voice anyway so
uh i think when they released it in
theaters too i think like when people
came to the theater like they gave you
like a packet of salt like so you could
keep
like put a circle around yourself and
like keep evil spirits away so you know
the movie follows a dude and his wife
the dude's name is norman and he's
played by peter wingard
now i think that peter wingard this
might be his only like his main film
role because i think he was mostly known
for british tv
it's weird because the original novel
conjurewife
was set in new england i think but
because this was filmed
um you know this was made by american
international pictures and they made it
in the uk
uh you know with mostly a uk cast and
crew
so they just like transported it to
somewhere in england i don't even think
they say like where it is exactly
peter wingard i'd seen him before but i
think he's better known for
being on british tv and he was also um
peter quint in the innocence which i
think was a non-speaking role if i
remember
uh that movie so yeah so he plays the
lead
i think that peter cushing was actually
supposed to play the lead but he either
couldn't do it or he was ill at the time
or something
but anyway they couldn't get him so uh
peter wingard kind of got brought in the
last minute so he plays norman taylor
now norman taylor
is a college professor i think it's
psychology i just i
wasn't sure if it was psychology or
anthropology or something like that but
at the very beginning he's giving like a
lecture
about superstition and about like why
people believe it and things like that
so they're setting him up
right from the jump as super rational
you know he just thinks all of the
superstition
stuff is just [ __ ] and uh so that's
kind of
where his character's coming from he's
just very adamant that there's no such
thing
as you know supernatural anything
apparently he's
not been at this uh he's not been at
this job very long
and it's implied or it's kind of like
exposited
that there are some older members of the
faculty and there's like a lot of
backbiting and [ __ ] going on because
they're afraid that he's going to get a
promotion
that some of the other ones wanted and
they're just like oh you know he's so
he's so he's so much younger and it's
like his um students really seem to like
him he's like the highest rated
professor
so there's a lot of like bitchiness and
jealousy going on
you know campus politics and things like
that uh so
you know so he's getting a lot of kind
of shade from uh some of the other
members of the faculty now he has a wife
named tanzi
and tanzi uh he at first doesn't realize
this
but as they they have like some of the
other professors and their wives and
[ __ ] like over for bridge one night
and they're all kind of every like i
said they're all kind of like throwing
shade even though
man you'd go to somebody else's house
and then like start [ __ ]
picking on them and like do all these
kind of little underhanded compliments
and [ __ ]
it was just like yeah it was just so
[ __ ] but uh so yeah so they come over
and that's
there's all that going on and then after
they leave tanzy
seems to be like looking for something
like she's freaking out going where the
[ __ ] is
where is and he's like so what are you
looking for oh nothing just like some
shopping list i lost i'll make another
one it's no big
and then later he's up trying to find
like his
pajamas and they're in the laundry and
so he has to like kind of bust open this
drawer like the drawer gets stuck and he
has to pull his drawer outs or her
drawer out so he can get in the thing
and then he finds in her drawer there's
like this little
uh this little i don't know what it is
it's like it's like this little
container like with little
white skulls or whatever all over it and
there's like a dead spider in there
and so he goes to his wife he's like
what the what is this all about
and she said oh you know when we were in
jamaica and i was hanging out with
uh with that guy and he gave it to me
it's like a good luck charm
so norman's kind of like okay whatever
it's just kind of like it's a souvenir
and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so as the story goes on though um and
norman starts like finding
all these other weird little things like
stashed around in
little corners of his house he comes to
the realization
that his wife tansy actually believes
in not really black magic but she has
all of these kind of like protection
spells
essentially that she's put around the
house so
he being like a big rational skeptic and
everything he confronts her he's like
what the hell is all this [ __ ] like
he lays it all on the table it's just
this ridiculous amount of like all these
little poppets and all these little
things
and she's like look this this [ __ ] is
real uh when i was in jamaica that dude
i hung out with i guess it's like
supposed to be obeya or whatever but
they don't call it that in the um
in the movie but i think that's kind of
what it is
so she's like you know i saw him you
know bring
a woman or a little girl back from the
dead like there was this woman that said
she would trade her life for the little
girl and he did it like he did the spell
and she came back
and i and you know and she's like and
why do you think
that your career and everything has been
going so well
is because i've had all these protection
spells on you she's like because
some of the other people at the college
she doesn't know who it is
but she's like some of them are trying
to hurt you and they're using black
magic to do that
so i have all these spells to protect
you
of course he does not believe this and
uh in kind of a dick move
i have to say um he makes her burn all
of the
protection spells now since this is a
horror movie
uh it will not surprise you to learn
that pretty much the minute that all of
this stuff gets burned
[ __ ] starts to go seriously seriously
sideways like uh
in his career and all these other things
he gets uh
one girl that's um or one young woman
that is
uh that kind of had a little bit of a
crush on him or whatever like in one of
his classes
she kind of flips out and like calls him
like does kind of a [ __ ] like a does
like an obscene phone call well i mean
obscene for 1962.
and then she accuses him of rape
and then her boyfriend tries to or like
threatens to shoot him and it's like
they're trying to get him fired and it's
like all this [ __ ] like he almost gets
hit by a truck
there's just all this crazy [ __ ] that
goes on and
so as the movie goes on like and his
life gets worse and worse he's starting
to think oh
you know maybe there is something to
this black magic [ __ ] that tansy is
doing because
it just gets worse and worse somebody
sends them a recording
and the recording is of a lecture that
he gave
but there's also this really horrible
like high-pitched
sound that seems to have some kind of
like
black magic or hypnotic kind of effect
because when he plays it
um you know the power goes out and
there's like you know there's something
banging at the door like it's a monster
but then like he gets the door because
there's nothing there
so it's just like all this crazy [ __ ]
starts happening and he starts becoming
more and more convinced
that maybe there is something
supernatural going on
now at this point i don't know like
usually a movie this old
i would normally just not care so much
about spoiling it but i feel like a lot
of people haven't really
seen this one and i really liked that i
didn't know even though i'm pretty sure
i read the book like i said it's
because i read a lot of fritz leiber's
uh stuff like his short stories and
everything like when i was a teenager
and i'm pretty sure i read this one too
but it was so long ago that i didn't
really remember any of the plot points
you know what i mean all i remembered
vaguely that is
kind of about witchcraft and it was but
it was set in the you know what was then
the modern day
so i didn't really see where this was
going like at first
i mean up to the point where you know
yeah he burns all the
witchcraft stuff that she's keeping in
the house and you know shit's gonna go
sideways then because like i said it's
only like
half an hour into the movie and this is
a horror movie so you know that
either black magic isn't gonna turn out
to be real and she's right or something
else is going on
but after that point it kind of goes off
in these really really interesting
directions i was kind of thinking
for a time i was thinking maybe she was
evil and maybe she was like doing some
kind of thing
with it with you know that seemed like
she was
trying to protect him but she really
wasn't and so
you can't really tell which way it's
going because it goes in these real
strange directions
she starts to act kind of strange almost
like she's hypnotized like not all the
time
but she does weird [ __ ] like um
after the whole uh thing with the
monster or whatever it was like knocking
on the door and then he opens the door
and
nothing's there she realizes um you know
all our protections are gone
and to save you i'm gonna have to
sacrifice myself
like the story that she told earlier
about the kid in jamaica and everything
how somebody had traded
uh their life for the little kids and
she has decided that she wants to do
this so it's like she [ __ ] runs out
of town like to their cottage and
i guess she's gonna like drown herself
or whatever but then he chases her and
like he intervenes
and then he gets to a point where he's
trying magic to save her
and then at the end like i said i'm not
sure i want to spoil it but
it turns out that there is somebody
else involved as well so the way that i
thought it was going to go
was not really the way it went like i
didn't really guess where it was going
and it's interesting because i was
reading some kind of contemporary
reviews about it that came out at the
time
and one of the reviews that it was kind
of predictable and i'm like
was it though i didn't really find it
all that predictable
but it's like well i didn't really you
know up to a certain point it was but
then after that i just had no idea where
it was going but that like i said i like
that
um and the way that i thought it was
going was totally not the way that it
went
so like i said maybe somebody else would
find it predictable it's like oh i just
saw that coming a mile away
but i really really didn't i don't know
and i was really paying attention too
it's not like i was even doing
something else and i even had the closed
captioning on so i could catch all the
dialogue and everything like that which
i've been doing more and more lately
because i'm getting deaf as [ __ ] in my
old age
but uh yeah so i like to make sure i
don't i don't miss anything
but yeah so if you have shutter like i
said i'm sure it's in the um
on the us shutter because i just watched
it pretty sure it's on the uk shutter
might be on some of the other uh
countries as well because i kind of feel
like
this maybe this is um you know a movie
that's not it wouldn't be that expensive
to get the rights to so i assume that
shutter has it on probably most of their
platforms and if you really dig
60s movies if you really dig [ __ ] about
witchcraft
this is a really really good one like i
said it's a british film i feel like
not a lot of people talk about it and
it's easily it's one of the best like
60s horror movies that i've seen like
from that era you know and especially
one of the best american international
pictures like one of the ones they
one of the ones they put out and i mean
you can totally tell
um i think i forgot to mention too that
the screenplay for this
was actually richard matheson uh started
it
and then uh it was also kind of like
worked on by charles beaumont
and george baxt uh all of whom you know
obviously richard mathison super super
famous
uh and a lot of them did a [ __ ] ton of
twilight zone episodes as well
and this one kind of has a little bit of
a twilight
zone feel to it but
not but i don't know but more cinematic
and i guess like the
the cinematography is gorgeous i mean
you know it's black and white it's just
these beautiful
uh shots i especially like all the
close-up shots of um
tanzy's face she's played by um what's
her name i was gonna say linda blair
it's not linda blair it's janet blair
who had actually previous to this i
think she'd only done musical comedies
up to this
time so maybe this was like the first
horror she'd done or the first suspense
that uh that she'd done
and uh so yeah so this has a really good
and it was also directed by uh sydney
hayers oh and remember when i said
earlier that the
that the fritz labor novel conjure wave
had been
adapted in 1979 uh that
movie was called witches brew it had uh
terry gar in it and richard benjamin
and lana turner was in it too which i
think i've seen that but like i said it
was probably probably a kid that seemed
like something that would have been on
cable all the time
so yeah so this is the second adaptation
of this novel
you know i can't remember the other two
well enough to
say whether this is the best one but
this is a really really good
movie and it's just it's funny that
a movie this good would kind of like i
don't know if i'd necessarily like fell
between the cracks but
the fact that nobody really talks all
that much about it
is just kind of a crime because
i don't know i just found that there was
just something about the vibe of this i
really liked it's super
entertaining um i just found it
just a really fun watch and it's like it
just kept surprising me i didn't really
know where it was going like the
suspense was really good
the acting was really good it was just
like a fun fun movie and i really really
like [ __ ] about
black magic and charms and all that kind
of stuff too and i like that it was set
in like a contemporary
setting like a you know like a college
campus with all the
you know with all the backbiting
[ __ ] like trying to get promotions
ahead of this guy and they're like use
some black magic to like [ __ ] up other
people's
chances and [ __ ] like that so i thought
that was like a really good but like i
said it's not funny it's not funny at
all
uh not really i don't i can't even
remember any kind of levity in this
but i don't know there was just
something like really really
entertaining about it so if you have
shutter
uh i would definitely remem recommend uh
checking this one out because i really
really liked it and i really had a good
time watching it
and uh that will do it for this flickers
of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one bye